we're going to learn about the Memento
pattern and coding or software design
also known as the snapshot this read
here that we're going to start with is
by refactoring Guru there's the website
huge shout out to them don't look at my
internet history guys jeez should have
went in a privacy mode I'm I'm messing
around anyway appreciate you guys for
tuning in if you enjoy this video or
you're going to leave don't forget to
hit like first to help that means a lot
helps a lot to support and I'll leave a
comment with whatever you want I'll try
to answer all of them within the first
few days and uh yeah let's just talk
about Memento and a little bit about
expectations for this video essentially
I'm going to be coding it up in C plus
plus and I'm going to start with the
example from this website but we're
going to modify it a lot and talk about
a lot of different angles so essentially
what I came the conclusion I came
through on this is there's approximately
four different
um pretty pretty well known ways of
doing this and in this example they show
one which is probably the best in my
opinion but it doesn't mean you
shouldn't know about the others because
the others well as you'll see some
languages lack the support
to do this main method so you might have
to use one of the other methods of
implementing the Memento if you're not
using C plus plus or something I think
it I think it's mainly like PHP I don't
know all the languages man all right PHP
doesn't have this method notably but
we're going to stick with C plus plus
anyway that's what we tend to do on this
channel in case you're not familiar with
that
um yeah let's let's go Memento is a
behavioral design pattern lets you save
and restore the previous state of an
object without revealing the details of
its implementation so it's sort of like
the undo button you can also use it as
saves sometimes or a version of it for
saves um yeah so let's dive in a little
bit more I'm not going to talk too much
we're going to dive into the code very
shortly here but I'm going to at least
try to hit the main points like the
overview or what it essentially does so
you know it saves a state and it
restores a state but it does it without
revealing the details okay we'll get
into that now you all know it's pretty
simple to to just make a copy of a
struct or something along those lines or
copy a bunch of variables and then
restore them you should know how to do
that if you're a coder in any sense you
know if you know how to make another
variable the same type and assign it
something from one that's already
instantiated you know that's a copy so
this you know this is something you can
just hack together and put in there and
chances are you have but with this
pattern it makes it very maintainable
and very easy to expand very easy to add
to basically any any class and there are
some drawbacks we'll get into them but
uh yeah the standard problem with
classes is you have all your member
variables as private which means uh well
here they say can't copy what they
really mean is can't access so something
trying to save wouldn't be able to
access all those private variables you
could make a bunch of Getters and
Setters but is that really how you want
to design well that's up to you but
generally this uh doesn't use a bunch of
Getters and Setters so that's nice
because it's not going to be that giant
chunk of repetitive code and that's
essentially what you would have to do to
get around like the private problem here
it can't copy so we don't do that that's
just too clunky for uh what we want to
do so momento is going to be better and
they say hey your public data is unsafe
well we might get into this later but
for one of these methods you have to
make it public but for the others you
can keep it private
so how to make copies of the pro objects
private State question mark question
mark That's essentially what we're going
to solve
here's a little diagram of their example
now keep in mind with these examples if
you're anything like me you can study
this graph all day and still have no
flipping clue what it actually means you
know and I know you can really dig in
and understand it but for me personally
I kind of have to see the code so we'll
get to that soon
um but this is supposed to be a diagram
of how it works now essentially you have
what they're calling an originator which
is over here and that is basically what
you're working with that's what you
might want to take snapshots of and you
can see they've put methods here for
make snapshot and restore and restore
take some Memento is what they're
calling it you don't necessarily have to
call these snapshot Memento you could
just call it like whatever we're going
to stick with this though but I always I
say this a lot in all my videos because
people really get hung up on variable
names I know I do and
like these words in these boxes they
don't matter they could be a b c d and
you know some functions but it helps to
uh for them to make some sort of sense
so they're talking about the context of
a text editor with these examples that's
why you see text cursor pause selection
current font whatever it could these
could be anything though they could be
positions if you're saving the state of
a 3D object or something like that like
3D positions you can have a lot of
different stuff but for sake of example
you could think of these as a b c d e
because who knows what they really are
you know anyway so we got make a
snapshot and restore so what's a
snapshot now the snapshot has all these
same member variables as this editor
basically everything you'd want to
potentially save
so they have a little save button with
chains who knows what that means they've
got a dotted arrow with a triangle who
knows what that means something about
interface something about save operation
that's why I don't understand these
charts it's never clear what all these
mean so
um I don't know well why is this in a
dotted line box who knows but I think
what they're trying to allude to with
this graph and it's not their fault that
I don't understand the graphs let me be
clear I think it's it's purely a me
thing the point is I don't think it's
going to work for everybody if it
doesn't work for me it probably doesn't
work for a lot of people so what do we
got over here interface momento
all right and in this interface they
have a git name and a snapshot data so
we kind of have to unpack what this is
some Memento interface that has git name
and it has get snapshot how it's date
okay snapshot date all right and they
have a history and a command thing and
something that's talking to make
snapshot and restore and uh down here
they call this the caretakers so we're
seeing three main parts we're seeing an
originator we're seeing some whole kind
of snapshot Memento system and a
caretaker you could probably call this
caretaker something like a mediator it
might follow a pattern pretty close to
that actually if you want to look up
mediator at some point but essentially
you want a mediator or caretaker does is
it helps handle the interface between
two objects and in this case it's this
Memento interface that handles editor
and snapshot by calling these functions
and it also I believe the caretakers
where you're going to hold all these
snapshots so it's going to be the one
that's doing this whole restore and
passing in info and grabbing the mix
snapshot data using specifically this
Memento interface confuse that good good
me too let's get to the example and
it'll make a lot more sense after that
or at least it does for me
and kind of goes without saying but you
know I gave you the link to this webpage
if you really want to read all this
stuff and dig in a little more you can
go visit the webpage no one's stopping
you I'll even leave a link down below
but I'm going to kind of skip a lot of
this and we're going to get into the
code now okay here we go we're in our
design patterns repo link to that down
below it's basically where I'm just
putting all this code and I've made a
new folder here called Memento already
got the cmake done and we just have a
main so the main has all the Memento
code up above just already ready to go
then down at the bottom I've got a main
to test everything out so we're not
separating out into a new file Okay so
we've got some pretty standard includes
here I O stream Vector string we'll be
using those let's just go from top to
bottom here and I will explain all this
stuff so we have our Memento class now
notably this is an interface we can tell
because well the virtual keywords the
virtual Destructor and
mainly this equals zero means there's no
definition so if you inherit from this
class you inherit from this interface
you have to make these methods you have
to make your own version of these
methods
that's just part of interfacing and C
plus plus and this uh whole equal zero
thing so uh let's go to the next one so
next I have a con what they call a
concrete Memento and obviously it
inherits Memento so we've got it make
our version of these functions for that
but they also add a few things here in
this Memento they add a state and a date
those are private so nobody can access
them so we're keeping track of state and
now you can see here in the case of this
example this is pulled just from that
web page as our starting example
their data or their state what they're
calling State here is basically the
state of the object or the save it's
just a string
now in your world this is probably going
to be some other struct or class that
has all the info but we're gonna we can
we can work with that a little more
later if we want to play around we'll
play around at the end so you can see
they have a Constructor a little public
Constructor and the Constructor takes a
state you gotta construct this Memento
with a state that's really important
because you can't just create one with
no State it's got to have something
already there so you can't really just
create these easily you've got to have
something ready to go and as you can see
it just sets the state and the strings
in this case
but consider it could be any object so
there we once again set the state not
entirely sure why they do that twice
might just be a bit of oversight on
their end kind of odd
but that's not going to hurt anything
compiler will probably optimize that
away anyway in some way all right so
they also are using a bit of time or the
C time from the uh time Library which I
don't see included here I don't know if
it happens to come with vector or string
accidentally but I believe we should
have here time.h that could be wrong I
don't know we'll correct it later if it
needs to be or it might just be C time
all right so all they're doing with
these mementos is when you create a new
one it's also going to create a time
stamp of when you created it which is a
fine feature to have you might as well
so that's why they got this string date
here to keep that and the way they
obtain it is they make a Time T variable
called now and set it to time zero this
is part of the standard Library there
so you can look those up if you need
more info and they set the date to the C
time now now what C time does is if you
pass it one of these times is it returns
a
a care pointer which is essentially a
string so that's why how they're saving
it to the string because C time is
returning the time as essentially a
string all right so cool create a
Memento with a state and it's
automatically going to make a timestamp
cool what else do we need well we got to
implement these functions and you can
see there's a state here overridden all
it does is return the state which needs
to be the object type string here
so that's fine and we have a git name
and you can see what get name does it
basically takes looks like uh returns a
string of starting with the date and
some stuff about the state so it's
basically the name of the little save
hash in this case they're using a date
plus the state's substring data Upton up
the a characters or nine characters so
because they're struck or their object
for state is just a string that's why
you can do all this you might do it a
different way like you might use the
date sure but you might not be able to
do this if you're only holding like
integers and floats and stuff so you can
get creative there and make cool names
they're at least all going to be
different because the date time stamp is
always going to be different as you
create them unless you can magically
create two of them at the exact same
time which is going to be pretty hard to
do but
I guess the point of me going on about
this is to just let you know that you
gotta adapt if things are going wonky
for you like if you have been
accidentally beating date stamps at the
same time and object names of the exact
same name well
your names might overlap and is that
going to cause problems I don't know it
depends if they're in a stack anyway
with an undo button it might not matter
too much but if it does matter you have
to come up with some ideas to adapt this
is the point the date
uh is just the date just Returns the
date so we've got all those implemented
we've got some private members for what
we want to store
so that's essentially the whole Memento
right there now let's check out the
originator this is something this is
what we're going to pull this state from
essentially so here it is it's not
inheriting from anything so this could
be any class any class in your program
that needs a save essentially
well you've got its state or its
internal data which is private that's
the main thing that needs to match up
with your mementos and he needs to take
all that private data that you would
want to save and restore now they've got
some just kind of various code here that
just generates a random string which is
kind of interesting because essentially
you need some some differing data and
they just made a little system to make
random strings and we can walk through
it I guess we would will briefly but
it's really not super critical important
to understand to understand uh the whole
Memento thing it's just their way of
making random data so they've got a cons
care of alpha numerical just the whole
alphabet
and all the numbers upper and lowercase
and they just get the length of this and
then they make a variable called random
string
and they use the Rand function which we
won't be able to use unless we include
Rand here so let's do that
and they use the modulo operator on the
string length to go somewhere into this
Alpha numerical
care array so essentially they just do a
plus equals this is going to add to the
string so they just go for the entire
length of whatever this thing was and uh
yeah
or this length comes from this input
generate lengths of 10. so they just
basically end up making a random string
of all these characters
yeah that's essentially what this is
going to do so I think we've walked
through it enough just you can see the
brackets to index in there it shouldn't
crash because this modulo should never
be able to go above string length it's
impossible you don't know how the modulo
operator works it's a math function uh
definitely look it up if you don't know
it because you got to know it as a
programmer
so I'm not going to over explain it
anymore I'll leave that to the math book
stuff
but definitely look it up you can look
it up on C plus plus reference I usually
tell you to all right well and then it
Returns the random string so just some
code to make a random State basically
and then here's their public functions
uh they started out with the state if
you want so they got originator that
takes the state and I
just a string they've got some work so
of course your class is going to do
something essentially well it should
they've just got some generic random
strings so essentially when you call do
something they just change the state
that's all they do really here with this
Generate random string which is kind of
cool now they've got a save function and
this save very important to know what
happens here it returns a pointer to a
Memento so what's a Memento uh well it's
this thing it's this thing
since it's a pointer it's got to be a
pointer because well you can instantiate
this base one it's interface only but
when it's a pointer you can put anything
that inherits it in that spot
so we're creating a new concrete Memento
and its state is whatever the state of
the originator is right now so there we
go that's essentially a backup of the
state and it's going to be returned now
note that it's not saved within this
class so where does this data go it
creates the data it returns a pointer to
it but it doesn't save any reference
itself to it so it doesn't really it
doesn't this class doesn't know what to
do with it essentially and now we've got
a restore method note that these are
public so anyone can call these a
restore method takes a pointer to a
Memento same case it's got to be a
points or two momento so you can pass in
any kind
and then you just set it to its state
and you see how they get State here
through this interface function they
don't have access
to this here this private data in the
concrete Memento they don't have access
to that so they have to use this public
function that gets the state and that
was implemented right here in the
Memento makes sense
so still we're doing things properly
with data here is the point
and that just all that does is restore
its state to whatever whatever you pass
in there so you pass the momento and so
since clearly this class you know this
originator class you can you can
publicly press save and restore but you
don't actually have any access to this
internal data there's no get State this
automatically does it internally you get
this Memento access but with momento you
don't have well you have a uh you have a
copy of the state essentially so even if
you get the state via this method it's
still just a copy so you're not able to
mess with the original data all right
but to interact with these and interface
with these and make them work together
we lastly need a caretaker this is kind
of the uh
this would be like the the inner logic
of your program that kind of ties some
things together uh the caretaker
mediator whatever you want to call it
they call it caretaker in this example
so what does this have well it's got
your stack of undos which is just a
pointer to all these mementos we've got
a whole Vector of them so we can fill
that up as needed anytime we hit save we
can just add it anytime we hit restore
we can just grab the last one and and
hit restore essentially is what we're
going to do and we've got also a pointer
to the originator pointer to the
originator somewhat interesting here it
depends how you're gonna do it if you're
a true mediator you'd probably keep the
actual copy and manage the memory it
looks like here though they're not
managing the memory to originator
they're assuming you instantiated
originator somewhere else and then later
you instantiated this caretaker
and when you created this caretaker you
already have the originator you just
pass it a pointer it saves its little
internal reference so this is more like
an originator reference I would usually
call these just because it's not
managing the memory here it's just
taking someone else's instantiation
and we know that because we don't see
anywhere in here where it says new
originator okay
because if not we would say
you know if we could store our own
version of originator somewhere in here
you would see a new somewhere in here
you would see a delete or you would just
see this directly on in the memory like
so no pointer that's already
instantiated all right but since we
don't we can see that we want someone
else's originator to work on essentially
so this is going to work on that and you
can see here well they do delete the
Mentos at the end that's good because
you know these mementos are public or
not public sorry they're private these
mementos are Pointers it's the word I
meant to say so we do need to call
delete on them at some point and we
already went through the entire
originator and we know that it doesn't
handle memory anywhere here
and it is creating stuff when you hit
save it creates something but there's
nowhere in here where it deletes
whatever it's making there and that's
where the caretaker comes in it's going
to do that
um we'll see that here shortly
all right so we got a backup now this is
essentially the save button so from the
caretaker looks like you've got to press
back up and when that happens it just
pushes back a new save now this is sort
of interesting here and this is where I
got a little uh I don't know queasy
looking at the code I guess because I
was like wait a second you're using the
mementos method backup to call Save but
the problem here is you have save public
and the originator so any client could
call Save and what's good what's it
gonna do they're just gonna they're
gonna lose the memory probably it's
gonna memory leak basically so there's
kind of a bit of a failure there like
maybe what I would probably do
is make this private or protected no
yeah private and then make like friend
class caretaker
and that way only this caretaker class
could ever call Save and restore and
that way the client can't just like
create a bunch of mementos and like do
who knows what with them but probably
not delete them and cause a big memory
leak so this way oh this is pretty
specific to C plus plus this whole
friend class thing there might be a
better way but I would recommend doing
that so there's one little edit we're
going to make right off the bat just to
kind of make it a little safer
um so yeah backup basically just calls
save as you can see
and it puts it in this stack of vectors
so we're keeping track of it and we know
we're going to delete a later set that's
looking not too bad it's looking pretty
good we got an undo button
and the undo button is going to well
first thing is going to say let's make
sure the Memento size is greater than
zero basically this one's just a weird
way of displaying that logic so it's
just greater than zero basically it's
what it's saying there but with the not
you know a zero is going to be false so
they want to say not false which means
it has something however you want to
write it's fine I like this just because
it's a little easier for my brain to
unwrap if I'm skimming through the code
when you have to think about not false
okay but it's a size so when it's not
zero yeah it's just you know a little
extra logic steps but anyway let's move
on so here you can see with this undo
first of all they grab a pointer to the
back Memento they just
uh copy the pointer not the data I just
take the very last one let's dot back
there on that vector and then they pop
it off of there they destroy the back
one well they don't destroy it they
release the pointer but that's okay
because we have access to that pointer
right here it's the very final one
there's no more stored on the vector so
you got to be careful about this kind of
thing with pointers
um
so let's let's keep checking this out
all right
it tries to restore the memento
so let's take a look at what happens
here now restore
takes a pointer it looks at the state
now this could you know if they don't I
guess if it's null he would throw so
that's maybe why they have this catch
here but there's no throw within this
function directly it's probably just
because it's a pointer I'm not I forget
if try catch uh catches null pointer I
don't typically check that way
personally
all right so it tries to restore the
Memento and if it fails if it throws an
arrow they call undo which basically
calls this function again until it
returns
so I guess what they're doing here is if
it fails to restore the last one try the
one before that and so on and so forth
until it either gets one
without throwing or the size is zero
sort of a weird way to process your undo
in my opinion but it is what it is and
they've tried to make it somewhat safe
however they did leave a memory leak
here so that's pretty important to note
uh let's think about this here yeah
if I'm not mistaken I might be mistaken
I'm trying to unwrap my head around this
but I think they left a memory leak
because well okay we've got a pointer to
the memory that we just popped off the
vector this is the very final pointer to
it right now
and then we try to pass it in to the
originator in the re originator now has
that pointer so it it now has access to
that last data state
and then what happens here is it makes a
copy of the state
inside the Memento and it saves it to
this state and now when this restore
goes out of scope and this undo finishes
that original data from this momento
which is going to be like a string let's
see here
a string and a date that's going to
still be on the stack
see what I mean I don't know if that's
going to make sense to you if it does
awesome you understand pointers but
essentially since they're making a copy
here 90 I'm pretty sure they're making a
copy now the compiler will probably
optimize this away and it won't end up
mattering possibly possibly I don't know
it depends how it implements this it
should do a move a move would be better
here because it would essentially say
you know we would just
it would not do a copy and it would just
say that this data is the data basically
um
I think I'm saying that right anyway so
when these functions leave this pointer
which has access to that state goes out
of scope there's no more references to
that data that we copied into state so
we're going to have an extra copy of it
you know we're going to have it here
this dot State's going to have what we
want that'll be fine but whatever was
here is just no longer accessible okay
I'm trying to make that clear because
this is like the hardest part of C plus
plus is understanding what's happening
with data in my opinion at least and uh
that's kind of the point of C plus plus
is to be able to carefully manage it so
we're going to carefully talk about it
occasionally because it matters a lot
for getting the fastest code you want
all right so what we should do here is
we should at the end here go delete
Memento basically and that will delete
the state that has been restored because
we copied it anyway since we did a deep
copy there and that's just the way this
state function is going to work because
it returns a copy of a string now if
this was a reference like something like
this it would be a different story
because it's returning access to the
original data not a copy of it when you
when you do it like this it returns a
copy so it's making a copy of that data
so that's why that would happen
okay well we're kind of running out of
time so I'm going to skim through the
rest of this I think we've gone through
most of it uh undo function you can see
some of this needs a bit of work just to
properly design it you can whoever code
it up probably rushed through it and
didn't do a whole lot of debugging but
things like this here would show up
should show up as a memory Leak with any
memory leak Checker program uh you
should get some warnings or errors there
so
just because of the way that's all
handled all right well last thing they
have a show history essentially Loops
through all your mementos and shows you
the names nothing super special there
just looping through the mementos and
showing you all their names
but that's a nice little function a
little show history and here we have the
main which is going to make our uh whole
example go you see the instantiate a
originator here with some
super duper supper pup or so well I
don't know whatever then they make a
caretaker and you see they pass it this
originator as we talked about earlier
then they call care take her backup
which we know is just exactly the same
as colon originator save except
originator save doesn't you know
nothing's nothing's store in the Memento
no one's holding that pointer that's why
we gotta have this caretaker intervene
but with our improvements see originator
doesn't even let you call Save it's just
gonna say nope unaccessible inaccessible
that is better that is better than the
root than the way it was before because
as we discussed that's going to cause
problems so that's the point of uh
putting this back up on the caretaker
then we see a do something which we know
is just going to change the data then
back it up again so you see we're
changing the data
save a state change in data save and
state and so on so we don't save after
this last one but then we just do a show
history and then we do a couple undos
and then at the end we delete these all
right so let's give it a run see what
happens all right cool so let's walk
through this zooming in again there's
the initial state
um saving originator State doing
something State changed doing something
State changed so they they made it
pretty verbose with all these sea outs I
think there's some sea outs in this do
something that shows this new state yeah
they got originator and caretaker so you
can see what
so you can see what class is calling it
all right and then there's the list at
the end that's how they displayed it you
can see the date comes in pretty clear
and uh there's the first
nine or so letters and then we do some
rollbacks now rollbacks
we're not showing anything after doing
those I guess we could uh show at State
how do we do we have a show State uh
function here
no all we have is a do something oh we
could just make a quick show state
show current state
and uh yeah let's just copy this down
yeah that's that's fine for now we just
want to be able to call this
after each of these undo's just to
confirm that they are doing what they're
supposed to do
of course we gotta have the originator
call that
all right let's see what we get here
same code
rollback it says this current state is
at roll back again says this current
state is this it's currently not
updating the state
it's just staying as this last one so uh
what are we doing wrong here all right
this is the part where I go full derp or
went full dirt earlier when I was
looking at this undo logic so you can
see I'm at a break point here and I just
took a look and it's just returning
every time on this undo so it's not
actually doing the undo's it's because
of how I made this if the size is
greater than zero returned err that's
wrong if the size is greater than zero
we can actually undo so we don't want to
return it's when the size is is zero
so we could say equals equals this would
be a fine way
to do this code I like it better than
the I don't know we can just leave it
the default I guess there was some Merit
to just having it like this right if not
size it just reads so awkward to me if
not size
I like equals zero better so if size is
equal to zero return because there's
nothing to undo all right let's go
now stopped at my break point but uh
there it is we're starting the roll back
that's where I hit undo and I'm just
going to hit continue we'll go through
the rest and take a look at the code
all right looks like it's rolling back
correctly now we got a restore State
there and uh well we're actually saying
it twice now because I put that current
state function in there
I was overlooking the fact that they had
it right here already since it was
skipping over it but no matter we can
just uh we can just delete this extra
line not too big of a deal but this is
what we wanted to begin with okay so now
you can see it is actually rolling back
correctly current state is this here
after a rollback it is now that previous
state after another rollback it is now
that previous state again and after
one more
it goes back to its very original one so
we made four changes we made four undos
or three changes and three undo's we're
back to the original state it is working
as intended so there is a
pretty standard way of doing it this is
probably the best way to do it
uh with this interface class if you
can't do interfaces I'll talk about that
briefly here so essentially if you can't
do an interface if you just gotta get
rid of this get rid of this
things change a bit obviously you
wouldn't need override here well
basically what you have to do is just
it's just make these public and let it
have direct access so
if you can't use the interface for these
type of functions you just got to expose
it not a whole lot around that for some
languages it still works it's just a
little bit more dangerous and people can
misuse it easier so you got to watch out
for that
um rather than talk about all these
different methods I'm going to leave you
with the reference right in your face so
here we go
the Wikipedia entry on this is pretty
good and covers a lot of stuff including
some classic ways it was implemented uh
such as for the pseudo-random number
generator and it also talks a little bit
about where it came from uh who created
it um originally and that that kind of
stuff which is kind of cool info they
also make some mentions of other ways of
using it but essentially it's what we
went over the originator is responsible
for saving and restoring but not
necessarily
for storing these backups so they assume
the client or a caretaker will be
requesting these mementos via save and
they can control when restore is called
to pop it back in there so there's a
little bit of variety of ways you can
use kind of that caretaker or client
depending on how you're calling the save
and restore so you could
you could in theory say hey it's the
client's responsibility to manage these
mementos of saving and restoring like
here's the type here's what it's going
to return and here's where you restore
as but sometimes I might not supply a
caretaker sometimes you might need to
make your own Vector of mementos or
whatever so there's kind of One Design
difference there in ways it can go the
way we did and the way we uh edited the
code and fixed a few things is we assume
that there's always going to be a
caretaker because we actually shut off
that's having the client save the client
has to use the the caretaker they can't
they can't restore or they can't save
and hold a copy of a Memento that's
that's where we did that private thing
and the whole friend class caretaker so
there's one little difference there and
there's a lot here they go into some
more examples but essentially it's the
same stuff I've already said but if
you're having trouble getting a grasp on
this I would recommend just trying the
examples yourself first and then you
know reread re-watch if you need to but
all right let's see what else we can
find here it's for varieties I'm trying
to find the place where I originally
read this stuff I'm talking about and I
don't remember anymore okay well I guess
another thing where I was kind of
calling the uh caretaker like a mediator
in this case they're sort of referring
to it more as a command just because of
the way it has uh commands I guess
so yeah they seem to be more saying the
caretaker is a command object so I guess
it passes in the Memento commands is
what they're referring to
okay no I'm slightly mistaken here so
what they're saying with command here is
if you're using command you obviously
you optionally have mementos in there so
it would save the state of the object
just before the command gets executed
meaning that you know basically
functions like an undo because anytime
for example if you're making a text
editor anytime you press a new key it's
going to save the state before putting
that key change in there that way if you
hit undo it just undo does it so that
makes a lot of sense
so sorry for the confusion there
says you can use it with the iterator
which sure makes sense if you're just
sticking with a vector most of that's
already done for you but if you need to
implement your own doing some special
stuff that might be a really good
experiment too
there's mention of the Prototype being
just a simpler alternative now if you
remember prototype it's basically where
you make a copy of something in a very
specific way and then you just copy it
back it's a lot like the Memento just a
little bit more simple really
fairly straightforward if it doesn't
have links to external reference or
links are easy to re-establish it says
okay so maybe check out prototype if you
want to compare and contrast but they
are actually a lot of ways quite simple
they basically do the same thing as far
as restoring State because prototype is
basically made to copy the same state
while momento is more about restoring
previous States but hey if you were
saving each current state as a prototype
in to restore later you know there's a
bit of mash up there so I guess it
depends how you implement it what you
call it in some cases but Memento kind
of I guess people are used to hearing
that for the whole undo process
all right and the other one was well
Memento without inheritance I tried to
find the PHP example it looks like at
least modern PHP does support some
inheritance so that works about the same
but the other way of doing it is without
inheritance and that's having a little
trouble finding examples on that I've
read about it somewhere at one point but
I can't seem to find it again you know
it's one of those things but essentially
you just have to expose some things as
public usually those data members
probably be more prototype-esque in this
case and uh yeah I think that's all I
got for this video hope you enjoyed once
again don't forget to hit like uh leave
a comment subscribe if you want to see
more stuff about C plus plus you can
join the patreon if you want to get on
Discord and have some further
conversations or ask me anything
especially after this video has been out
a while I might not be responding to
comments much anymore it's just the way
it goes but uh yeah this code will be up
on GitHub and I highly advise checking
out those sites and reading more if you
want to keep digging in playing around
more but get out there do some code and
make some make some examples have some
fun
all right I'll see you next time peace
out guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you